when you've put these five numbers
together they give you a really good
idea of
like much better than just the mean or
just the media or the own
um of how the data sort of spreads out
okay
so we're going to do this um together
graphically
with what's called a box of risky chart
or a box one you guys have seen these
before
okay now we've got three sets of data
here and i would love
us to draw the box of whisker plots for
each of them they're not complicated
so i'm going to walk you through how to
do each one
we'll just do the first one first and
then we'll point out all the bits and
then you can do the second and third
ones on your
own the first thing you need is uh if
you've got a ruler there and if you need
to borrow
right here so it doesn't take
yeah that's fine okay here we
so go you need is a horizontal axis
now you'll notice oh you need something
else
okay yeah sure um remember
so the question was how do you work out
quartiles when you've got not just
10 numbers but like say 100 numbers or
something like that now remember
um having a look and you can see it
right each of the quartiles is kind of
like taking
uh the top half of your scores actually
that's not in order i mean this one
the top half of the scores and then
finding the median of this guy right
that's what the third quartile is
and in the same way you look at the
bottom half of the scores these guys
and then you find the median there and
that's your first quartile okay
so therefore to find quartiles is really
the same question as finding
medians you just have to do it more
times so that shortcut we had before
of n plus one on two right i would say
you know um let's actually say there
were um a hundred scores
okay if you have 100 scores
the median divides it into two right so
how many scores will be on either side
of the medium
it should be 50 50 right 50 50.
so then think about the 50 and you
should be able to say
of this where is the median in that set
of 50 well i'm going to do this n plus
one on two thing right
this is my new n n plus one will be
51. i divide by two so in this place
i'm going to get 25 and a half which
means that the median
of this guy which is q1 should be
halfway between the
25th score and the 26th score so i don't
have to do all of my crossing off
i can go straight up i can count up to
the 25th one and then take the average
of those guys
does that make sense so that's that
still is like i mean you know you can't
avoid you have to get in order
if you've got such a large data set
they'll probably give it to you in order
because
like you get it that's we don't want to
just eat up your time but this is the
process you'd go through
what's the significance of the plus one
that's a good question um if you think
about how many scores you've got for
instance this is perfect you've got 10
scores
right if you were just to say all right
take those 10
and divide by two that should get you
half right right well if you take the
original
ten scores you divide by two maybe i'll
do it with
these are all actually happening in bad
examples because the fifth and sixth
scores have the same score
if you looked at ten divided by two you
get the fifth score
but the fifth score is not the median
right because think about the fifth
score
here is how many scores are below it and
how many scores are above it
there are four and five so it's not even
it's not the median
right so the median is between the fifth
and the sixth scores
to get us between you've got to um add
one then divide by two
okay uh and the example we looked at
yesterday sort of map that out
all right now you've got your horizontal
axis there by now
there's no vertical axis because on a
box and whisker plot
vertical length it doesn't mean anything
it's just kind of arbitrary okay
so then let's have a look at um well
yeah let's do
let's do this one i think it's more
interesting okay so when you have a look
at this second data set
the five numbers i'm after are the
minimum
the maximum and these three quartiles so
you need to choose for yourself an
appropriate horizontal scale
that will get all of those numbers onto
your graph okay
so i think we could justifiably start at
zero
and end at say we can't entertain how
about any of 15
what do you think okay so i'm gonna go
zero to fifteen i'm gonna put some fives
as my
markers in between this so maybe you'll
do that with me
so i've chosen my horizontal scale
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to mark in all five of these
important numbers
onto my horizontal
scale here now i'm going to put a
vertical dash
for each one of the numbers okay so i've
got two that's going to be
about there my next one up is four
then what have i got next what is my
median it's seven isn't it seven so it's
going to be about
one there my third quartile
is ten it's right on there and then
my maximum value is eleven so i'm pretty
close to that
there you go so these five dashes they
represent
the five numbers in my five numbers
sorry to turn this into a
box and whisk a plot you look at the
middle
three and you draw a box around them so
so there's the box in a box of whisker
plot chart
and then to make the whiskers in in the
middle
i'm going to draw one line like
and there's your graph okay now not as a
requirement but i think it is helpful
particularly when you're trying to read
something important obviously
i personally like to mark all of these
important numbers onto my scale so you
see how i've only got 0 05 10 15 etc
with another color dotted lines whatever
can distinguish this for you
i'm going to draw from each of my five
numbers
down to my horizontal axis
okay and then if any of these numbers
aren't actually
already marked out i'm gonna do it right
so i said this one was
two and then i think i have four seven
ten is already there
and there's eleven okay
um you don't have to i'm just making
this so it's clearer for you
if you had all the same color that'd be
okay all right but the important thing
is that if those numbers are important
to you
i think you should be able to see what
they are unambiguously
okay that's really all there is to
boxing whisker parts of course if i gave
the plot to you
and it asked you can you interpret for
me you're just going to be doing this
but in reverse
okay so can you make a start this is 11
i
just skip over yeah
yeah that's it so this is your you might
like to add this as well there's your
minimum
there's q1 q2 q3 and your
okay okay